[Music]
so many of you have had questions about
the school year so we have been
collecting them
and wanted to take them directly to the
people in charge
joining us now is dr carla lauria who is
the chief academic officer at ccsd thank
you so much for your time this evening
we greatly appreciate that doctor
we do have several questions from our
viewers so let's begin with the first
teresa roach mchugh she wants to know
what is the district going to do about
the magnet programs
she says her daughter is in her senior
year at northwest and it's a very
hands-on program
thank you for having us and for allowing
to answer some of these questions that
are so important for so many of our
parents
distance education of course is not
ideal but it's needed
um during the current pandemic so for
magnet programs all
we understand that they are hands on and
in many cases it is important for the
kids to be
in school um but our students
will have the opportunity to engage with
the teachers
virtually our teachers are finding great
ways
to do the best they can to reach out to
the students
um allow them to participate in
activities in on online activities that
are engaging
we do know that distance education is
not ideal we want students back in
school but when it
needed a pandemic our trustees are
receiving updated health
information every 30 days they
will be determining um based on the
information we
we receive when is a good time for
all of us to be to go back to classroom
of course keeping safety
in the forum in the forefront
doctor our next question comes in from a
viewer named kelsey chatwin
she writes in what are the schedules
going to look like for preschool
and kids with ieps will students who
need help with speech
still get to see a speech teacher
yes the schedules for preschool will
look similar to
their kindergarten schedules they will
follow the normal schedule or doing that
normal hours
if the child is in half day preschool
it's going to be of course a shortened
day if it's in a full day preschool
the student will have opportunities to
engage
in two ways with the teachers one of
them is the
synchronous way we have heard that word
um
more often lately than ever but that
really means
um to be able to participate in a
face-to-face
um activity with the teacher in a live
activity with the teacher
virtually so it is just like we are
doing right now
via the technology then we are going to
be able to access the teacher directly
and also we will be able to to
learn via asynchronous um
model lessons uh which really means
uh the students engage in in their own
learning independently with activities
that have been specially
selected by the teachers to continue the
learning of the students
um students with ieps students like you
said who may need speech they will
be able to connect virtually with the
teachers
at this point um the teachers will need
to use their discretion and determine
whether they feel comfortable to come
into the school
whether they feel safe to come into the
school
and um in either work at the school
or from the school or work virtually but
they will be able to engage
in in the special needs
opportunities that they may have based
on their ieps
okay dr lorea mandy mccabe wants to know
the following she wants to know if there
will be any additional tutoring services
available yes there will be a digital
tutoring services
student services have have always been
managed at the school
level and there will be opportunities
for students to engage
in smarter group or one-on-one sessions
virtually
with their teachers as the teachers feel
the need
we're also as a district working with
different organizations
to organize probably community
organizations who may be also available
to provide services to students
and if they feel comfortable they may be
students may be able to attend those
sessions face to face dr lorea this
question comes in from scott r joseph he
writes in what is going to happen with
the credits
towards graduation
um as usual there was their online
credit retrieval options for students we
also have the nevada learning academy
and that will be functioning as normal
they have always been
virtual so that will continue our
students also
will have the ability to graduate early
from high school
if they have the credits that make them
eligible to do that
at the same time educators will be able
to reach out students in very
unique way in very individualized
manners so that they can support
students if to recover credits if that
is the case but students will continue
being able to recover credit towards
graduating
dr carla lorea joining us live on eight
news now
doctor we thank you so much for your
time and providing that information
for our viewers we do appreciate it
thank you
plans do look a little different for
private and charter schools this fall
eight news now reporter sally hatamia
spoke to principals superintendents and
ceos of a few different schools
and gives us a look at what their
learning plans involve
i think it's a challenge when you shut
down athletics and you shut down the
arts and you shut down all the after
school activities it's not just the
education it's that social piece it's
where the kids find their passion after
school when that all gets shut down it
takes a toll on everybody
the typical back to school looks a
little different for the various charter
schools
with some opting for classroom settings
while others
are staying virtual our plan really has
two options for our families one is to
come back five days a week face-to-face
and then we also have an option for
families who aren't comfortable yet
sending their kids back
we're going to tape every single class
every day and not everyone is doing
everything
exactly the same we're sponsored by
clark county school district
we made the move to online learning
and our face-to-face component was just
suspended
temporarily our board decision that was
made a little over a week ago
was to return all virtually and when it
comes to health in schools
the ceo of faith lutheran middle and
high school says it will be taken
very seriously some of the things would
include we're taking temperatures every
morning doing some health screening
we're extending passing periods we have
one-way hallways we're serving lunch
from five different places
we're not gathering for chapel every
week like we normally would in addition
desks will be cleaned between every
block and every student and teacher will
be required to wear a mask
social distance and even wear a face
shield right now our numbers show about
six percent of our students are going to
choose what we call option two to stay
home
and about 94 percent of them seem to
want to come back five days a week
superintendent at odyssey charter school
says they've been fortunate to have
scheduled their blended learning model
and feel fully equipped so we're going
to begin online
and then what we're hoping is that as
things improve
with copic 19 that we will
slowly begin to shift back into our
online
combined with our face-to-face component
of our program
and over at somerset the principal says
the goal is consistency
is that perfect for all of our families
no
no matter what we do it's not perfect
for all of our families
but we had to look at what can we do
to be consistent with our kids and even
though all plants are different
everyone has the same need for
flexibility we're going to rely on the
southern nevada health district
and or the governor and or the cdc if
they would need to completely shut us
down we'd be ready to pivot immediately
into fully remote learning if we have to
sallie jaramillo 8 news now some school
plans changed after the governor's press
conference last week
charter schools that were set to open
prior to august 24th
will now be virtual until that date and
of the 19 charter schools that are
opening
today six switched from the hybrid model
to distance learning
those are discovery charter school
aquipo academy
founders academy quest charter academy
and signature prep
an additional 19 charter schools are set
to open
the week of the 17th so far pinecrest
has switched to full
distance others tell us they are still
trying to figure out what they plan to
do
for a list on more of the private and
charter school plans check out our
website 8newsnow.com
a lot of parents scrambling with that
new information coming up don't forget
to vaccinate the shots children will
still need before school starts
up again that's next on the valley's
news leader